- Popcorn...
Do you know popcorn was
originally cultivated in Mexico?
There was this funeral
urn with a Zapotec god,
that had a crown that contained popcorn.
Guillermo González Camarena made
one of the earliest
color television systems,
and he patented it in
Mexico and in the U.S.
Gum?
- Oh thanks.
- Modern chewing gum is now made
from the juice of sapodilla trees.
The Aztec would use
it as breath freshener.
Hey, do you know chocolate is believed
to be invented by the Olmecs?
They used to crush cocoa beans
and then they mix it with water.
Boom! The origins of chocolate.
Also, Victor Celorio
created The InstaBook Maker,
this is technology they can
print books super quickly,
and they don't have to print thousands.
- Hey yeah, my tire's
flat, can you come help?
Oh, someone's here, never mind.
Hey...
- Hey.
- It's flat, do you think you
can help me put on the spare?
- Do you know rubber dates back from
the times of the Olmecs and the Aztecs.
They have this tree you can extract latex,
it's a rubber tree
that is called Castilla
elastica, pretty cool.
- Yeah cool, but can you help me
put on the spare tire, or you know, help?
No? You're just...
- That salad.
- Yeah.
- Caesar salad.
- It's generally agreed that Caesar salad
was invented by Caesar Cardini,
he had a restaurant in Tijuana,
on Independence Day,
he had to improvise the salad
because there was too many people.
- Cool.
- Yeah.